[Music]
without world's eSports would look
completely different the stage shows
you're used to in every game from csgo
to fighting games the production quality
you hope to see in every eSports stream
the level of play you want from the
biggest tournaments all started at
Worlds every year riot gathers the
biggest teams in League of Legends to
face off against one another the prize
pool isn't as big as some other events
but that hardly matters worlds is when
everything is on the line
[Applause]
for the longest time it was the only
international tournament that mattered
but putting all that aside world's
changed eSports and every year fans
hoped that riot can do it all over again
this is its story these days worlds is
one of the biggest productions in
eSports it's run as long as six weeks
takes place in massive venues all over
the world and dishes out hundreds of
thousands of dollars in prize money
alongside one of the sport's most
sought-after trophies the summoner's Cup
but the first worlds wasn't the event
we've come to know today now they're
wrapping up season one we really want to
continue to evolve the experience to
help establish it as one of the top
eSports titles in the world world season
one was announced just two months before
the tournament started with teams
determined through a set of regional
qualifiers epic gamer team solomid and
counter logic gaming represented na
against all authority fnatic and game de
came from Europe and zan and team
Pacific qualified out of SCA with the
teams in place the League of Legends
community gathered at Dreamhack summer
and yon shopping Sweden in a venue that
somewhat lovingly somewhat sarcastically
is referred to as freaks basement ladies
and gentlemen welcome back to the Omni a
convention center on shipping Sweden we
are here for the Dreamhack summer 2011
championship game the finals about to go
underway
$100,000 tournament held by League of
Legends and Riot Games obviously
Dreamhack summer didn't take place on
the bottom floor of League caster david
freak Turley's home but the whole affair
was pretty low-key especially compared
to its more recent iterations season 1
Worlds might not have featured the most
exciting high-level play by today's
standards but here's the mistake he
turrets around randomly getting himself
back in a rage and
which means actually let's save it just
walk back in rage pick up the kill but
at the time it was the absolute peak of
Pro League of Legends and it was only
the beginning
it's been an amazing end of our season 1
and like in like to have it said we're
just getting started season 2 is going
to be amazing
absolutely and thank you to everyone at
home you've really made this event such
an overwhelming success we thank you so
much for tuning in and you know we'll
see you next year
season 2 was the first worlds that riot
had planned in advance announced in May
with regional finals taking place
throughout the summer world structure
was more organized the prize pool was
higher and there were even more teams in
attendance it was the beginning of
worlds as we know it after the regional
winners have been declared the top 12
teams will then put it all on the line
during the season 2 World Championship
in Los Angeles California and all eyes
were on European stalwarts Moscow 5 good
job kid almost oh he does get taken down
doesn't get a chance to attack the die
falling to Moscow finds that cue Alex
he's coming up very big but it's time to
practice the double kill they're changed
undefeated is just too strong and this
completely spells Baron - 29 minutes
from Moscow five men pure and CLG Europe
time to play trying to get away from
this one yellow beets just a jump on his
face any minute now there we go the
shutdown comes in the ACE comes out from
CLG this is insane but few anticipated
the threats from the East azubu frost
and nauseum black sword dominated the
group stage this should do it indeed it
is gonna be magic sword going 3 and OH
in the group both Korean teams matching
up the victory therefore - absord
absolute
lutely outstanding football for both
these dates while surprise winners
Taipei assassins came out of nowhere to
take the top spot
[Applause]
and in the end they hoisted the
summoner's Cup
[Applause]
of course riot makes video games not
trophies and no one thought about the
fact that the winning team would
actually have to lift it which led to
the summoner's Cup Wayne 70 pounds the
heaviest sports trophy in the world
which some would argue is indicative of
some of the growing pains that riot had
to deal with at season 2 worlds in
general season two's world was bigger
and more impressive the grand finals
marked the first Western eSports
tournament to sell out a sports stadium
but riot wasn't as prepared for that as
they'd hoped to be the first and perhaps
most notable issue was the way the stage
was set up players receded in front of
the screen meaning they could just turn
around and take a peek most notably
azubu frost allegedly use this in a
match against Team solomid to get a read
on a cheesy level one tank and I want to
call attention to actually the team so
limits race brush so they saw how that
TSM shoved that top lane and a lot of
people went up there so cloudtemplar
made the move into TSM's jungle and
tossed a sapling down there at that
brush by the Wraiths camp which allows
them to see just what TSM is trying for
but by the end of the tournament riot
found four instances of screen cheating
even one from TSM dyrus who alleges he
looked back to prove that players could
see the screen and as soon as we saw
that pause we're like holy [ __ ] or PI
might not work
we looked straight to zoom frost and
chaos notices their players looking our
map looking at the mini-map and they
start like talking and then there's also
proof in the replay that there's been
paying that dart areas where we're
standing where they have no vision of
riot let the players off with a fine and
admitted it was their mistake but mark
one of the biggest scandals in
competitive league history on top of
that viewers at home experienced some
issues with the broadcast
the tournament was plagued by technical
issues which meant plenty of causes and
plenty of silver scrapes so we hire here
at day four the data was never meant to
happen it is the extended world playoffs
and as you can see the construction is
going on behind us right now hopefully
things will happen all to plan today but
riot took it all in stride world season
two was one of the most successful
widely viewed eSports events the West
had ever seen and riot used it as a
springboard to create one of the most
important eSports events in history
thank you for watching the season 2
world championships and we will see you
in season 3 good night
[Applause]
before World season 3 the West's eSports
scene was drastically different than
what it is today
tournaments were small often held in
hotels or convention centers dota twos
the International was unique in 2013 for
selling out a concert venue but ti2 was
tied to PAX Prime and not its own event
season three worlds was the culmination
of riots efforts to bring as much of
League of Legends eSports in-house as
possible instead of teams qualifying
through regional qualifiers after a year
of third-party tournaments they
qualified through riots own needs of a
machine has gotten so shocked it's eight
teams going in and competing for first
place riot set up the NA LCS and EU LCS
while licensing out league operations in
China de 10-cent garena in Southeast
Asia and OGN in Korea teams would
qualify from around the world for a shot
at the biggest tournament Western
eSports had ever seen season three world
was held in California again but this
time the grand finals took place at the
Staples Center a 21,000 seat basketball
and hockey stadium that hosted the likes
of Kobe Bryant and Wayne Gretzky making
it the biggest audience to attend an
eSports event in the West's history it
was a landmark for the scene and a sign
that eSports wasn't just some passing
fad it was growing and league of legends
was leading the charge but it wasn't
just those optics that made people pay
attention world season 3 was all about
the Korean hype train
[Applause]
SK Telecom g1 after Korea's strong
performance the year before all eyes
were on najin black sword Samsung ozone
and of course SK Telecom t1 in a young
mid laner named faker but SKT weren't
the only strong team in attendance
Moscow 5 s legacy lived on in gambit
gaming who put on a strong performance
in Group B got the crescendo down from
this one strangled thorns coming in
boydle going so very very low looper as
teleport down as well for look at him
taking so much damage we'll have to use
the barrier cataclysm goes out dari
gonna charge on through here comes I'm
gonna dig into they've managed together
slow down lupard charging on the way
back to all these turrets with that
ultimate Andy's ghost running and now
Alex movie misses the charm that's not
gonna allow him to look up the rise but
a two-for-one brilliant turnaround from
Gambon only trumped by fanatics utter
dominance in the same room and you
cannot run for this banana team they
chase everyone down on ozone 21 kills
the six a'queen hayes
and another surrender for ozone
meanwhile group a was ruled by SKT and
China's oMG and these teams might be
waiting on their supports Ultimates
right now like specials crescendo as
well as the strangle turns on thier but
oMG nevermind they don't wait strangle
Dawn's route goes now girls mid routes
Reginald thinking low looped and passive
pop once again but his tire is being
focused Cole gets of the kill [ __ ]
master comes on through and special
wildturtle
all locks over the back down then to go
go he just backs away takes their world
total Reginald tries to slide on through
but he just simply gives another kill -
cool and that was a 3 for 4 1 4 OMG in
Chinese champions royal
with superstar ad carry a newsie seemed
unstoppable in the bracket with wins
over OMG this is going to be a win for
Royal Club they are going to take down
their Chinese rivals two to zero
amazing performance to set in fnatic
they fly under whites they take down
whites if they can get hoozy they may
get the damage out with the DPS is still
there demon they're moving on to the
Nexus that was the big if when they
could go through it Jews he is alive
Jews he is doing damage it's royal but
as has become something of a world's
tradition one of the tournament's best
matches took place in the semi-finals
SKT and nauseum two Korean Titans clash
first spot and the grand fights hades
dating this one he's not going to be
able to escape me are they gonna keep
going through though in session gonna
dive in pink up break from the side
all of a sudden big as the first killer
towards Baker imprints of making he's
gonna do it from the tower
piglet peeks I would have been the end a
crazy crazy fight ends in three for two
fakers in trouble there that was a flash
body I love it he get you with the
ultimate no babies water he manages to
get caught the bug activated
nothing's gonna throw down a barrel that
explodes that's two kills now for sword
not gonna connect fakers still alive
it's not easy trouble
he's got the short wait so then there is
the short wave coming there but faker so
very low a question though
bacon
Gate ran together kill does gather kill
like they read those three of them
together
the first victim is watching the rhythm
sword on the retreat this is the big
tree but it was SKT and faker who struck
the last blow moving on to the finals
with a swept royal to lift their first
summer school the Nexus turrets are
potentially gonna go down they will be
the season three champions here at the
Staples Center ladies and gentlemen the
hype train is real
SK Telecom have one to throw fees in the
space of being together for six months
yeah this is like almost a new team and
not even say almost few months of last
year into this year season three worlds
was the beginning of a legacy that would
go on to define competitive the league
of legends it was the beginning of a
saga that saw faker transformed from a
young prodigy into a champion
turn the greatest player to ever touch
the game was also yet another sign that
North America a strong region in the
scenes early days was beginning to fall
behind the competition
TSM had attended all three worlds up to
that point but bombed out of groups with
a dismal two and six record c9 the North
American champions who dominated the NA
LCS under the leadership of hai lost 2-1
to fnatic and the quarterfinals fnatic
are gonna go through to the semi-finals
taking down the North American champions
cloud9
despite the enormous hometown crowd na
teams just couldn't cut it at Worlds but
the crowds didn't care
once the NA teams were out nationality
was left at the door fans came to see
the best League of Legends possible and
the teams delivered nobody touching
piglet they're all running away Baker
makes the fight continue puts godlike in
the fray and they're gonna take down the
turret whoa oh my god between the
storylines the quality of the play and
of course the incredible level of
production there was nothing more
impressive in eSports of that year than
words
sure ESL and Dreamhack were running
tournaments back then but they didn't
look like they do now TI was still a
year away from ten million dollar prize
pools and filling up Key Arena Evo was
years away from mandoline Bay and the
csgo majors hadn't even started yet
there's no question world's season 3 set
the standard for modern
riot set the trend and showed the world
what eSports could look like and most
that came after decided it was what
eSports should look like every eSports
tournament wanted to fill up the Staples
Center but worlds did it I really cannot
believe that I'm actually saying this
but that doesn't for the League of
Legends season 3 World Championships on
behalf of the entire broadcast team good
night thanks for watching
if season 3 worlds was riot proving they
could put on the biggest sports show in
the West season four worlds was them
proving it could work on a global stage
season four took worlds to East Asia
with matches played in Taipei Singapore
Busan and Seoul the finals were held in
an even bigger venue than the Staples
Center the Seoul World Cup Stadium a 66
thousand seat arena that was built for
the 2002 FIFA World Cup it was bigger in
every way with even more teams in
attendance riot opened up more spots for
Southeast Asian and international
wild-card teams to compete which began a
legacy of underdog teams playing spoiler
and messing with the competition
kaboom eSports may have finished last in
their group but their single win over
Alliance provided one of the most hype
least expected moments from the entire
tournament pushing Alliance out of
contention for a spot in the playoffs
our alliance
just happen but this time all eyes were
on Samsung white and Samsung blue two of
the best teams in Korea both teams were
strong but since blue had defeated white
throughout the year many saw them as a
slight favorite but after a shocking
three home victory for white in the
semi-finals and they do not hesitate to
drop the Nexus it's only gonna take
three Samsung white finally defeats Sam
remarkable fashion blues captain da day
the general handed his signature jacket
for the pawn to signify a changing of
the guard and with that jacket on his
back
pawn made sure to leave his mark the
city makes this serene folk they gonna
focus in on the Nexus itself
[Applause]
but season four world's wasn't the
biggest eSports event of 2014 after the
incredible show riot put on the year
before several eSports tournament
organizers stepped up their game most
notably the dota 2 community put
together the largest prize pool in
eSports history 40i4
with ten point nine million dollars
shared across the 14 participating teams
riot didn't increase their prize pool
for worlds in response to the fact and
stayed at just over 2 million taking
some of the wind out of their sails sure
Wyatt took determine on a grand tour of
Europe from London to Paris to Berlin
but somehow it didn't feel as big as
some of the competition on top of that
the tournament ran in the middle of one
of riots most frustrating metas the
juggernaut meta defined world's 2015
with the same champions being picked and
banned for most of the playoffs yeah
as for IDI cheese bans I think since our
on red side they may just be walked into
the gangplank mordekaiser and Elise yeah
partway into the tournament Gragas zigs
and lux were disabled as well bringing
champion diversity even further down
Gragas was one of just a few viable
junglers in a meta and without him fans
got very used to watching the same comps
Duke it out over the course of a month
the issue that appeared in game
prevented reignover from costing the
Gragas q spell and the referee team they
did investigate and exhaust every single
option to resolve the issue in-game
including allowing dragons to die and
attempt to resolve the matter as for the
games themselves Samsung's win the
previous season highlighted the Korean
Exodus which saw a number of LPL teams
signed top tier lck players in the hopes
of finally breaking china's second-place
curse at Worlds
this included all members of both
Samsung teams it wasn't the first time a
defending champion wasn't in attendance
to defend their championship but after
two straight years of Korean dominance
many hoped the streak would break cloud9
who ran the impossible gauntlet to make
it to Worlds 2015 looked incredible
going undefeated in their first week
stinky is eternal life but they gotta be
careful a big knock back in the calendar
forgotten this year goes down as well
but the tubs are coming through a double
kill four balls a triple kills all week
ctype axel chill already fruit carnation
the damages - now watch c9 completes the
eight and they complete the two old
worlds but couldn't keep the momentum
going and along with the rest of na went
winless in week two and then a
heartbreaking defeat though yeah thought
I getting essentially reverse swept
there queasy ought to zero more right
Obama meanwhile following TSM's
disappointing finish beloved top laner
Markus dyrus Hill announced his
retirement bringing the crowd to tears
and providing one of the league's most
touching moments now it's time to open a
new book right now my story ends here
but I still even with me gone
I still want everyone to support TSM and
I love all of my teammates
not only did Korea continue to dominate
the grand finalists Koo Tigers and SKT
swept nearly every team they played the
only team able to put up a fight against
either was kt rolster the third Korean
team at the tournament and in those
grand finals faker led SKT to victory
once again making the team the first
ever two-time world champions
Koo Tigers are falling SKT
your first ever two-time world champions
as a team
[Music]
SK Telecom t1 your two-time world
champions all eyes are on League of
Legends during worlds the venues wowed
the crowds and the champions display the
absolute highest level of play but
between the prize pool discrepancy North
America's complete disaster of a
tournament and the terrible meta riot
needed to ratchet things up for season 6
season 6 worlds did bring some changes
for one riot actually increased the
prize pool through fan contributions and
while it wasn't a scratch on TI's prize
pool the increase to 5 million dollars
was a welcome change then perhaps in
response to the sudden meta change ahead
of worlds 2015 riot played it on a patch
nearly a month old giving players plenty
of time to experiment with new pics like
the lillas Miss Fortune support and
installation really weird and to bring
it all together riot took worlds back to
Na back to the Staples Center things
weren't perfect but the tournament was
more exciting Europe seemed stronger
with h2k taking first in their group in
a tiebreaker match against wild card
legends Albus NOx Luna made a deep
tournament run becoming the first wild
card team to make it out of groups all I
want to say is that hey guys we are from
Val's car and they have told you before
being underdog doesn't mean being a
loser says home and Samsung Galaxy
provided the first-ever 5 game world's
grand finals against defending champions
SK
and Samsung Galaxy our pink dolphin
today tower
SK Telecom every challenge
[Applause]
but of course SKT prevailed turning
their legacy into a dynasty with three
World Championship titles under their
belts it seems impossible for anyone to
ever upset their place as league's
greatest team and faker as league's
greatest player but every dynasty has to
fall eventually world's 2017 took things
to China for the first time with a tour
through Wuhan Huang zu Shanghai and
Beijing ending the tournament in the
bird's nest the biggest venue in league
of legends history
[Music]
this time riot took things up with a
larger play in stage that saw the lowest
seeds from every region but Korea play
against the champions of the wildcard
regions for four slots in the group
stage gigabyte Marines provided 2017 s
fun wildcard matches taking games off
immortals and fnatic and while they
didn't make it out of groups neither did
two of the North American teams but
cloud9 ever the world's hopefuls made it
to the quarterfinals and took team w/e
to five games giving n/a fans just a
little more faith in their region
[Applause]
it's toric semi-final
meanwhile all eyes were on long shoe
gaming the first seed out of Korea and
new favorites to take s Katie's crown
unfortunately they felled a samsung
galaxy 3 Oh in the quarterfinals as they
take down their first opponent they are
the first to the semi-final and who can
really stop this team
while both misfits and loyal never give
up pushed SKT to five games back to back
a telecom t1 will be your second team in
the semi-finals claiming victory over
misfits gaming SKT masters of control
will take down the Nexus will take down
RNG and are headed to their fourth World
Championship final in the end
Samsung emerged victorious with a swift
3o victory over SKT learning their Org a
second world's trophy and ending the SKT
dynasty
[Applause]
their 2017 champion it shocked the world
but perhaps more importantly it shocked
faker who has moved to tears by his
first major international loss in years
[Music]
worlds isn't the only tournament that
matters anymore for league
there's msi to show off the
international strength and for eSports
in general tournaments like ti the
majors even Evo have stepped up their
production values to match worlds but
somehow worlds is still magical every
time it's not just about the best teams
in the world competing on the world
stage it's not just about the tours riot
makes taking fans from venue to venue
with a unique show in each one it's not
just about the extraordinary levels of
production that riot somehow manages to
top each year it's about what the
tournament stands for world's pushed
eSports forward
it cemented what the modern major
tournament should look like what it
should feel like for both players and
the fittings ever since that grand
finals at the Staples Center eSports has
never turned back
world's changed eSports every year bands
tune in to see if they can do it again
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button